we wait iconic fast food menu items in
the U.S and the UK and compared their
prices to see which country is getting
the most for its money this is food Wars
in the UK a small cheese pizza will cost
you 11.99 which is around 15.54 that's a
price per square inch of 21.8 cents
small in the U.S 949 which is about 12
cents per square inch
I know I got a small but apparently
they're also doing small peppers with
the small pizzas look how small this is
skimping on the peppers hey papa
an XXL cheese pizza in the UK will cost
you around
23.32 which is a price of 12.3 cents per
square inch
USA's extra large
15.49 that cannot be right sprinkle a
little math on that that's 7.7 cents per
square inch that is so cheap
so what can we take away from this well
in both countries the more pizza you buy
the cheaper it gets in the US the price
per square inch of a small is 55 more
than an extra large and in the UK it
shoots up to a huge 77 percent more
I mean it makes sense right I mean
that's how they get you they pretty much
are tricking you into getting more pizza
because it's cheaper per square inch so
you're going oh I'll just get the extra
large instead and then a year later
you're fat
[Laughter]
whoops it was such a good deal
UK that's 1.95 cents per 100 grams in
the US it's 2.36 per 100 grams that
makes them 21 more expensive in the us
and we're gonna weigh the Big Mac and
see if there is any difference in size
not sure there will be but let's find
out
foreign
how much a large fries weighs in the UK
that's a cost of 1.94 cents per 100
grams in the UK that makes them 14
cheaper in the US
next up for the US is our large which is
a 14 inch diameter 100 square inches of
Pizza in the UK would cost 15 100 square
inches of Pizza in the US would cost
nine dollars and seventy cents
that makes it 35.3 cheaper in the US
we want to make sure that you're getting
the same amount of filling as you do in
the US here in the UK so what we've got
here is a foot long Italian BMT on
hearty Italian with lettuce and olives
we're going to weigh it to see if the
quantities are the same
we're going to weigh the large fries to
see the comparison between UK and us
that makes them 15 more expensive in the
US
per 100 grams the US Whopper is six
percent cheaper
this is a crunchy beef taco supreme in
the UK the UK price is five dollars and
eighteen cents per 100 grams that makes
it 49 cheaper in the US this is a UK
chicken quesadilla
that's 27 cheaper in America
this is a Crunchwrap Supreme in the UK
this has an estimated weight and it
should weigh 146 grams if the website's
ingredients information is correct but
ours actually weighs 154 grams so we're
actually getting more than expected
worry about at hair over 150.
okay we're gonna weigh the cup and then
also the extras to see if what you get
really is a bonus or if it actually all
adds up to the supposed total 165
first we'll do the scale right so this
is supposed to be 411 grams let's see
what we got
what is this 170
woof guys that's not even close so our
regular cup of fries actually only
contained 165 grams Which is less than
half of what you're supposed to get
we're going to weigh the rest of the
fries to see if that makes up the
difference
so even with all the bag fries which we
assigned to the regular portion we're
still only looking at 276 grams which is
well below the portion size you're
supposed to be getting for a regular
excellent idea Harry I will do the same
now we are up to 275
still not supposed to be 411 so it looks
like we've been a bit short changed on
the fries because it was all given to us
in one big bag it's hard to tell which
portion came out small so what we're
going to do is add the little fries to
this one get a total figure for all
three portions and then figure out how
much we've been shortchanged overall
so we've done the maths and between our
large regular and little fries including
the bag fries we only got 830 grams
however we were supposed to get
1220 grams which means we've been
shortchanged by roughly a third here
with the rest of the bag fries the large
and the little so they gave us
851 grams of fries total
they're supposed to give us
1225. hey Siri
851 is what percentage of 1225.
69 percent
nice
so at least in our case it seems as if
the generosity of Five Guys has been a
bit overstated maybe they just overfill
smaller containers so you kind of think
you're getting more than you should be
whereas in reality if you measure it all
you're actually maybe getting less
so we're gonna weigh this burrito half
at a time to see what the total is
in the UK we can only get one size of
guac on the side it's supposed to be
four ounces we're going to measure it to
check if that's the case that's a price
of 3.58 cents per 100 grams in the UK
the US version is therefore 26 percent
cheaper
so which country gets more pizza for its
money in the UK a large cheese pizza
will cost you 15 pounds 99 that's a
price of 15 cents per square inch
the US large hand tossed cheese pizza is
about 13.99 which is about 9 cents per
square inch making it about 40 percent
cheaper than the same Pizza in the UK
we're going to weigh the double Shack
Burger to find out if it's actually the
same size in the UK as it is in the US
foreign
oh man ours weighs a lot less
significantly less what's up with that
Shake Shack
in the UK we can only get fries in one
size and this is it in the U.S we also
have only one size of fries
what I meant to say was let's see how
much they weigh
so all potion of fries came to around
188 grams what
this is 188 ours is like a little over
100 like when I say 105 I might be
generous it's a lot less
100 grams of donuts in the UK it's
costing you 5.96 that makes the American
donut 56 cheaper that might not make too
much sense to compare just one munchkin
in the UK and the us because I'm sure
they're all slightly different shapes
and sizes however what we could do is
measure 24 munchkins here and 24
mentions there and hope that it provides
a kind of overview of the average weight
foreign
this right here is a standard USA Krispy
Kreme classic glazed donut I want to
bite into you so bad
before that let's weigh it Pour 100
grams of glazed donuts in the UK you're
paying 4.39 that makes the American
donuts six percent more expensive
we're going to weigh 10 Plain Wings in
the UK and do the same in the US to see
how they match up
so 10 plane wings in the UK came to 290
grams which is an average of 29 grams
per wing
oh way higher dude 360 grams I needed my
calculator app to determine what 360
divided by 10 is and it is in fact 36
grams wow star average is 36 grams per
Wing here in the US so five plane
Tenders in the UK weighs 230 grams 200
what way over 300 on this one bigger
chunks of meat over here in the US
bigger tender chunks of meats
hahaha
that's not a good look for fries I don't
know how do I get this back in
and the large portion came to 255 grams
our regular is bigger than your large UK
dips in the UK only come in one size and
it's regular we're gonna weigh a cup of
ranch to see how much we get
now the big boy I I couldn't even guess
how much this container weighs before I
do this yeah closer to 300. this is
heavy this is like a half a bottle of
ranch
[Laughter]
bro
it is
440 440 grams of ranch
okay okay